let's cross the Americas. Here are the points. This is the story I'm going to tell you.
From Syria to the Pacific, the explorers set out to cross the oceans. They crossed continents in
pursuit of their dreams of freedom. The adventure was sometimes dramatic. Often it was the end of
heroes. It's not easy, but it's magical to create a brand new, beautiful country. Others took up
the beautiful path, going further, going higher, and making their dream a reality. Now they are
here, the Americas as you imagined them. It's up to you to make them the fantastic world that we all
dreamed of one day. May everything go my way to reach the end of destiny on this earth without
hoping for a land of brotherhood. Go back one last time to the north of the continent, Alaska,
the land of ice, because other men will arrive there. Did they come by land bridges? 10 or 12,000
years ago. Did they come in their light-skinned boats 4,000 years ago? Both are probably true.
Some are even said to have come in icebergs. Can you believe it? In any case, it is generally
agreed that these were the very first migrants to have populated the American continent.
The living conditions that these conquerors of the far north would have to face were among the
most difficult in the world. Okay, we should have waited to migrate. The weather is so bad. You know
very well that the hunt was disastrous and we have no reserves for the winter. Who is right? We need
to find something to eat quickly, otherwise we will starve. I know where we are. A few more hours
of walking and we will be in the right place. You should leave without waiting for me. I am a little
tired. But yes, continue on your way. We have to arrive before nightfall. Okay, but Piero will keep
you company. There you go. This is the right place. The sea is right in front of us. It's good this
way. It looks solid. Thanks for coming with us. You're probably thirsty. Look at the sun. Spring
is coming, kids. Oh, there was a beautiful jib lying on the ice flow. I approached in my boat to
throw my harpoon and suddenly another jib, a big one that I hadn't seen, came up from underneath and
boom. If you covered your boat with skin at the front and back, it wouldn't be able to take on
water. What did he say? What did he say? He said, he said that if you covered the boat with skin
like this, then water wouldn't be able to get in. Very good idea. Yes, yes, that's a very good idea.
Yes, really. So that's a good idea. Oh yes, for a good idea. Your system doesn't work. Yes,
but I would have thought it would work. We have to find something else. You know,
with prototypes, it's always like that. There's always some fine-tuning to do to perfect the
system. Let's think about it. Let's see. Let's see. Let's see. No. No. No. No. No. That's not
going to work. But no. Come on. That won't work. It can't work. It's completely idiotic. But no,
it's not right. No. No. No. No. No. However, it seems to me that there is a community. But yes,
That's a good idea.
I should have thought about it more.
Let's be modest.
Here's what you're going to do.
Oh, to me.
Yeah.
Come on.
A little smile.
You'll get your share too.
Let's give me a few punches.
But what's going on here?
What does that mean?
Master, the ice is melting.
What are we going to do?
Don't panic.
We'll just leave a small wall of ice and then build a house with pots on top for the summer.
Dinner is served.
Come on.
Let's go this way.
No.
Wait.
Chief, I'm coming.
I'm coming.
I'll help you.
I'll be sure to.
You'll get your share.
But this is the last time, understand?
And me, and me, my share?
Master, master, caribou, a herd.
Look, we saw them over there.
Winter will be coming soon.
We mustn't miss out on all this good meat.
What tactics do you recommend, master?
You know, I know many tactics.
First, there's the classic one.
We try to get closer to the animals by imitating them, but against the wind, right?
There's also the one on the lake.
But then, we'll all have to do it because we need a lot of people.
And finally, the one I'm going to suggest to you is also very classic.
Look, at least this winter, we'll have reserves.
And also good skins to clothe everyone.
We've just gone through another cycle of life of the peoples of the north and also of the northeastern part of the American continent.
Let's now look at the inhabitants of the northwest, the Thule.
They soon dominated the far north, supplanting the other tribes.
Fearsome hunters, they invented the harpoon with a detachable tip and waterproof jackets.
Houses buried underground allowed them to live comfortably, even in winter.
Lamps protected them from lightning and other things.
Have you seen how big they are?
Do you realize how much there is to eat in a fish that big?
It's whale season.
Come on, let's warn the others.
So, we'll be ready soon.
Tomorrow, we're going hunting.
Okay, now, all that's left to do is grease the seams.
That's good.
Let's warn the men in the neighborhood.
We need to appoint a leader for the expedition.
You have more experience than all the others.
So, I suggest you take command.
Does everyone agree?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
and I too know that you are a whale and I am a great leader, so, I will be the one in charge of
the hunt, that's it, that's it, but another time today, the men have chosen, slow down, wait until
she shows her belly at my signal, you will throw the float harpoons first, now, all together, ah,
ah, yeah, that's very nice what you're doing, can I see it, yeah, yeah, oh, to me, to me, to me,
To me. To me. I have the right. Come on. Run quickly and dry your clothes. Otherwise they
will rot. I have a little score to settle first. No. Women are not allowed to enter the men's house
here. Understand? I know. Yes. So give this dish to my husband. Would you mind doing it? But you
see your wife. It's true. She is much thinner than mine. That's true. But yours is much more
comfortable. Don't you think? Let's just swap them out and see. Great idea. Hey. You don't have
to bring all this good food. That's our boss. His boss is the one who wears the pants and I'm sure
she's giving him a good beating. Very funny. And how about a good beating? So, a big load of soup.
How about that? Sorry, boss. No, don't chase them away. They could be useful to us. But look how
small they are. There really isn't much to eat. Pierre is right. These animals could be useful to
us. You'll see. Over time, the ice flows will reach the bays and straits that prevent the whales
from sailing. Then, the Tules will set off with their dogs harnessed to their sled to conquer the
far north. They will thus cover the 12,000 kilometers that separate Beringia from Greenland,
and the other tribes they will encounter, like these Durets from the east, will disappear,
along with their more elementary civilization, absorbed by our ingenious, our courageous
conquerors. At the same time, somewhere in northern Europe, other men were also feeling
a great thirst for conquest. The Normans are Vikings. Eric the Red's expedition will not go
further than Greenland this time. 40 years later, two ships arrive inside of Newfoundland. They are
commanded by Torfinn Carl. Straight ahead, guys, there is land, and we are the first to set foot
there. Come and see. They have big hummocks and strange animals. What are we going to do, master?
The foreigners are all demons. We must slaughter them, master. Come on, let's calm down a bit.
First of all, we must go and see. So, make sure everyone takes a weapon. Also, take them a little
whale meat they may be hungry chief here are some men men what do you mean men question mark what is
he saying i don't understand anything this foreigner doesn't speak the language of men
well you hear he doesn't speak the language of men here take this let the others taste it it's
not bad not bad at all even if they didn't always understand each other the beginning of relations
between the two groups was cordial almost friendly but things were soon to go wrong no no no no i
disagree. One piece is not enough. Here, two or three pieces. Are you okay? No, that's not okay.
I have the sword I want. No, that's out of the question. We are forbidden to give our swords.
Look over there. That man stole a sword. Foreigners are bad men. They steal from us. They kill us.
We absolutely must chase them out of here. Let's go. Do you all agree? This country has become
unlivable for us. It is too dangerous. It is better to leave. So the Vikings will return to
their country and the Eskimos remain the soul masters of the far north. Soul masters, see,
the riches of the country will attract trappers and merchants and not always the elite. Alcohol,
pillage, rape, murder, famine, disease. These are the gifts of the newcomers and the Eskimos
will be decimated. Nowadays, their descendants practice more modern trades, keep their homes
with oil, live in prefabricated houses. And the noise of machines and engines replaces the howling
of dogs. America in the form of Atlantis. Here are North America in the Pacific. Here are the
I was once the Americas. This is the story that I told you. The titles times the